Remember how we talked about actually writing code to do intersection between
two rectangles? We've actually abstracted that away and actually turned it into
a function inside of gMaps. You can call gMap.intersectRect. The isVisible
function is actually a nice little helper that will pass in the viewRect and the
rectangle for this tile Into the intersectRect function to determine whether or
not this tile is visible to the current view rectangle. This is a helpful little
function that we'll utilize in a couple different places moving forward. Now,
before moving forward let's go ahead and write this intersectRect function so
that it takes two rectangles with top, bottom, left, and right values and
returns whether or not they intersect.